covet nineteen is devastating health
systems worldwide hospitals are often
understaffed doctors and nurses
overworked many without life-saving
protective equipment well into that work
we are completely overflowed health
workers are exhausted physically and
emotionally because this is awful this
is an inferno and after a grueling shift
it doesn't end there
some are isolating themselves from their
families returning home from work forced
to keep their distance from partners and
children some compare its life in a war
zone we are scared we're trying to fight
for everyone else's life but we're also
fighting for our lives as well because
we're also at the highest risk of
exposure it's tough and many shifts that
I've left from after finishing my shift
I've cried I have headaches every single
day before going into nightshift I was
having like chest palpitations chest
pressure just from like the anxiety and
fear I was like what was coming some
doctors and nurses are being threatened
with dismissal for speaking out against
working conditions and the lack of
protective equipment such as face masks
and proper gowns after 17 years treating
patients at a hospital in the US state
of Washington a doctor says he was fired
for publicly criticizing his workplace
and the lack of safety measures for
staff I do feel they're feeling the
pressure on from the press I do feel
their feelings of pressure from social
media and the community but I don't
really feel they fully comprehend the
potential damage to two health care
workers while his employer has denied
his sacking the incident highlights
similar cases as medical and emergency
workers rushed to save lives
many are updating their wills and
funeral plans to sorrow higher odds
jazeera